il faut remonter les manches mercredi la
cérémonie nationale aux victimes du
terrorisme dont il faut bien donner les
droits pour cent et montrer que de toute
façon si ab voilà dix mois la croissance
au delà même de savoir qu'il a
contribuée 7 milliards est en fait nous
annulons l'augmentation de la tva pour
12 viard
le président de la république par l'aide
bilatérale c'est pas possible je prends
de la hauteur je voudrais avoir ça aussi
à ses victoires
ça va pas du tout dans notre journal
c'est pas que ses confrères indices
quant à l'afrique montrer constantes la
cohérence et il ya eu des tentatives
tu vas et tu es talibans il ya eu des
attaques sur saintongeois ici nous
l'avions pas été les premiers il est
clair que le mali serait aujourd'hui
dans les mains des terroristes
nous avons une course dont nous jugerons
le résultat à la fin par au début pas au
milieu à la fin un élément langage fixé
en commun non plus mercredi on va parler
d'eux que politique par têtu et avoir eu
deux réunions l'une au qatar ses yeux
dans les yeux que ça et celui de la
déontologie et de la prévention des
conflits d'intérêts